1 messieurs bonsoir
18h44 l'assemblée nationale vote en
première lecture l'abolition de la peine
de mort en france
un vote massif qui va bien au delà des
clivages de majorité opposition 3 169%
16 contre en gros trois quarts 1 car on
sait que les sondages régulièrement
effectués depuis dix ans donne des
pourcentages inversée moment historique
donc à l'assemblée regardez bien les
visages des députés au moment d'énoncer
par philippe seguin président de séance
des chiffres du scrutin ils sont tous
empreints d'une certaine émotion
oui via ces images que nous envoyer
daniel braid ne sont pas prêtes je pense
que on pourrait essayer de les commenter
par avance avec paul lefèvre car paul on
le savait depuis l'élection de françois
mitterrand au vu de ses engagements
pendant la campagne électorale
et puis depuis l'élection d'une majorité
de gauche à l'assemblée on savait que la
peine de mort allait être aboli cela dit
la sade étude était beaucoup plus grande
sur ce qu elle l a remplacé c'est à dire
rien ou une peine de substitution
mais le problème de la peine de
substitution de remplacement plus que
celui de la peine de mort pour eux
menditte va d'ailleurs encore dominé les
trois autres débat prévu à l'assemblée
au sénat et à l'assemblée en dernière
lecture jusqu'au 1er octobre les
sénateurs en particulier veulent tenter
d'obtenir du garde des sceaux
des aménagements à son projet
d'abolition je sais par exemple qu'un
groupe de sénateur rpr étudie
actuellement une idée qui gérait une
sorte de solution de compromis et qui
risque d'ailleurs de faire réfléchir
sans doute de sénateurs et de députés de
l'opposition en deux en seconde lecture
alors cette idée est simple un homme est
condamné à mort si c'est la première
fois la condamnation à mort est ajournée
est commuée en réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité
mais s'il a déjà été condamné à mort ou
à la réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
alors là il est exécuté mais il l'est
par l'absorption de substances toxiques
ont fait disparaître la guillotine alors
ce compromis voudrait d'une part
habitués entre guillemets l'option
publique à l'idée d'abolition même
partiel deuxièmement d'autre part
répondre à l'émotion à la digne à sion
provoquée par les actes des grands
criminels récidivistes mais là
évidemment on se heurte on earth l'idée
profonde du garde des sceaux qui refuse
de discuter en termes des changes
l'abolition contre quelque chose en
verve interdite l'abolition est une
chose est un choix d'éthique sociale un
choix moral on est pour ou on est
content
ensuite ce choix fondamental et en fait
on étudie et on réforme l'aspect
technique de l'échelle des peines
criminelles en france alors en réalité
jusqu'à maintenant la peine de mort
était le pivot le symbole de la justice
notre système judiciaire
l'abolition est un autre symbole symbole
d'une autre conception de la justice
française à première vue le garde des
sceaux n'en démordra pas voilà donc ce
premier acte s'est joué hier nettement
1h15
vous invite à regarder donc ce qu'était
l'énoncé des résultats du scrutin par
philippe seguin député rpr
abolitionnistes et vice président de
l'assemblée nationale
c'était le prix d'une séance
d'aujourd'hui
le premier qui je le rappelle était
ainsi libellé la peine de mort est
abolie
nombreux votants 487 suffrages exprimés
480,2 majorité absolue deux cent
quarante deux pour 369 contre 116
l'assemblée nationale a adopté
42 membres de l'opposition ont ajouté
leurs voix à celles des socialistes et
des communistes
parmi eux jacques chirac rpr et michel
d'ornano udf zubar a voté contre
côté socialiste un seul vote style et
une abstention le garde des sceaux avait
dû ferrailler une bonne partie de
l'après midi pour obtenir court qu'un
additif ne soit apportée à cette
décision
il avait promis à ceux qui dans les deux
camps souhaitait obtenir des assurances
pour que les criminels ne soient pas
remis
trop rapidement en liberté le 2 avril le
parlement serait saisie des textes sur
l'exécution des peines et le plus vite
possible au plus tôt dans un an que les
chefs de ces peines serait révisée un
certain nombre de députés rpr et udf ont
refusé leur suffrage lors du vote sur
l'ensemble des six arctique
motif le texte gouvernemental ne prenait
pas en compte leurs préoccupations
ils n'ont été qu'une dizaine et maître
badinter dit sa satisfaction
c'est une majorité qui a dépassé la
majorité
c'est important significatif que sur
l'essentiel c'est à dire l'article 1er
on ait eu une majorité si large si la
vague 25% de l'opposition actuelle
réunis autour de l'abolition un certain
moment dans l'histoire et dans votre
moscou sur les nerfs les soviétiques on
ne plus en plus de mal à tolérer la
place grandissante comprend solidarité
en pologne ils ont sévèrement tancé les
autorités de varsovie leur reprochant de
tolérer une propagande anti soviétique
malveillantes en contradiction avec les
engagements en tant qu'allié et la
télévision soviétique de nous envoyer ce
qui tout à fait inhabituelle des images
de manifestations hostiles à solidarité
manifestation organisée à kiev en
ukraine
philippe jannet comme pour appuyer
davantage des mises en garde officielle
la télévision soviétique a diffusé ces
images d'une réunion dans une usine de
kiev où les ouvriers ont condamné à
l'unanimité les mener antisocialistes du
syndicat libre solidarité et demandé aux
dirigeants polonais de faire preuve de
la plus grande fermeté en soulignant
ainsi les réactions des ouvriers de la
base
moscou cherche à contrer l'effet de
l'appel lancé par le congrès de
solidarité demandant la création de
syndicats libres sur le modèle polonais
dans les autres pays de l'est appellent
considéré par l'urss comme une
provocation révoltant
le kremlin semble décidé à ne plus
tolérer des audaces de solidarité dans
un message du comité central du pc
soviétique à stanislaw kania on dénonce
l'actuelle campagne anti soviétique qui
atteint des limites dangereuse et qui
vise selon moscou a arraché la pologne
de la communauté socialiste et à
liquider le socialisme en pologne nous
attendons du parti et du gouvernement
polonais poursuit le texte
qu'ils prennent des mesures énergiques
et radicale pourrait mettre fin
l'avertissement est nette reste à savoir
si les dirigeants polonais ont les
moyens et la volonté d'une épreuve de
force avec solidarité
réponse b américain washington accuse
moscou de chercher à intimider les
polonais et puis pendant ce temps
détournement d'un avion polonais par une
dizaine de pirates de l'air
détournements sur berlin ouest
les cartes de l'air ont été arrêtés et
seront déférés devant un juge de
berlin-ouest la campagne française de
l'un des bras droits de lech walesa a
été jugé indésirable en pologne
françoise breton qu'il partage la vie du
syndicaliste et noon pas luca a dû
quitté varsovie à la demande des
autorités qui jugeait sa présence
inopportune
pour martine gilson elles nous disent
que sont les conditions de la vie
quotidienne des ouvriers polonais
surtout pour une mère de famille une
quantité d un problème quand je vous
disais est très difficile moi même
vécu je les ai sentis moi même ayant un
petit enfant je comprends que la
situation d'une mère polonaise qui a un
petit enfant qui n'est pas sur le matin
en se levant à 5 heures du matin elle
pourra acheter du lait pour son fils
en faisant la queue une heure parce que
le magasin août à 6h et c'est un résumé
je crois qui peut vous donner une idée
des difficultés de la vie quotidienne où
tout est rationnée où les étalages sont
absolument vide
ceci dit la population est persuadé qu'
il y as possibilité en pologne qu'il ya
au moins un minimum de victuailles un
minimum de choses qui devraient dans un
pays comme la pologne existait ceci dit
je vous dis les difficultés sont énormes
les polonais ont font pas
justement je suis très heureuse d'avoir
la possibilité à la télévision tant que
française de m'exprimer sur ce problème
par rapport à cette question car à la
télévision polonaise est passé une
interview avec un français qui est venu
en pologne en disant que je n'avais pas
vu la famille je dirais que s'il
s'attendait à voir en pologne et ventres
ballonnés des petits biafrais évidemment
il n'a pas trouvé la famille mais s'il a
trouvé un pays industriel un pays
agricole riche où la population n'est
pas certaine demain de pouvoir donner à
manger à ses enfants je pense qu'on peut
dire que la fin d'août en pologne
aujourd'hui sauf breton qui comme l'une
des plus anciennes dirigeants de
solidarité anna valentino ville s'était
invité cet après midi au meeting de
rentrée de force ouvrière avec à la clé
un discours d'andré bergeron qui a lancé
un appel solennel pour la défense de la
politique contractuelle
de son côté la cftc est inquiète devant
le dérapage de l'inflation et la csl la
confédération des syndicats libres a dit
par la voix de son secrétaire général
auguste blanqui qu'elle était contente
du gouvernement mauroy il se comporte à
notre égard beaucoup mieux que les
gouvernements précédents at il dit la
politique précisément fin du comité
central du parti communiste qui s'est
réuni pendant deux jours à huis clos
ses dirigeants ont demandé à henri fils
bas et à ses amis de cesser leurs
activités fractionnistes vient surtout
préparer le 24e congrès de février
prochain et ils ont lancé un appel de
fonds pour renforcer la presse comme une
équipe en difficulté financière en ce
moment mais bien évidemment l'essentiel
c'était le regard du pc sur la situation
présente politique et économique
plusieurs aspects de la situation
économique et sociale sont préoccupants
le chômage la hausse des prix les
licenciements cela montre le haut niveau
de réforme a effectué comme l'avait
souligné notre campagne présidentielle
voilà en substance l'évaluation de la
situation politique par le comité
central aujourd'hui tout en soulignant
que le pc est partie prenante de la
majorité et du gouvernement
les communistes remarque l'importance de
l'action des travailleurs pour conquérir
des droits et des pouvoirs nouveaux
une action que le pc veut encourager
pour favoriser la réussite du changement
dans cette perspective pour les
dirigeants du pc le rôle de leur parti
est irremplaçable
autrement dit le parti veut garder
plus que jamais son identité son image
de parti de combat
et puis s'agissant denrées fils d'un
ancien membre du comité central et
ancien secrétaire de la fédération de
paris le comité central estime que lui
et ses amis en sont arrivés à
l'organisation d'une tendance au sein du
pcf en contradiction complète avec les
règles d'appartenance au parti ou bien
henry fils d'un de ses amis rentrent
dans le rang ou bien ils poursuivent
leurs activités fractionnel et cela veut
dire qu'ils choisissent eux mêmes de se
mettre hors du parti
depuis des mois les membres de rch
réclame un vrai débat à l'intérieur du
pc ils ont été sanctionnés au début
d'été aujourd'hui le parti sans les
exclure leur demande d'être conséquents
avec eux-mêmes donc de partir ils ne
peuvent combattre systématiquement la
direction est lui déjà une réponse de
l'un des intéressés c'est une attitude
catastrophique pour l'image du prochain
congrès pas question de nous soumettre
chaque rallye 2010 de la santé
n'assistait pas à ce comité central et
là vous le savez peut-être engager un
tour de france de la santé première
étape c'était aujourd'hui il le nord pas
de calais la région la puce ou
médicalisée de france et il a annoncé un
plan d'urgence de rattrapage pour ces
deux départements il a dit par ailleurs
que le développement de la prévention
seraient prises en compte à la fois par
la sécurité sociale le patronat et puis
l'état puis fidèle à son habitude il a
été sur le terrain des visites coup de
poing quelque sorte chez renault à
usinor et au lainière de roubaix c'est
tout lainière que martin alain vigneault
et jacques doo et en ont profité pour
enquêter sur la situation sociale des
ouvriers surtout des ouvrières là bas
dans le textile le personnel ouvrier
surtout féminin lainière de roubaix
elles viennent souvent de loin ces
femmes qui descendent de l'autocar
viennent du bassin minier du
pas-de-calais
elles se sont levés entre 2h30 et 3h du
matin pour faire jusqu'à 50 km l'autocar
comprendre leur kwassa 5 heures l oms à
jour trois heures de trajet qui s'ajoute
aux 8 heures de travail pénible avant de
retrouver leur seulement dans ses usines
de 26 hectares
elles vont remplir une série de tâches
souvent répétitives avec 20 minutes de
pause en tout ici elle assure la
manutention dans l'atelier suivant ce
sera la filature
regardez bien cette ouvrière elle a en
charge 6 à 10 face vingtaine de mètres
chacune où elle va surveiller le
déroulement les fils huit heures durant
elle va marcher des kilomètres tout au
long de ses faces repéré au toucher les
fils cassé et bien sûr les réparer le
danger de roulement et permanente donc
pas de cheveux longs pas de bijoux
pendant pas de robe ample bien sûr
attention au risque de doigts coupés et
tant pis pour la station debout
permanente
voici maintenant l'atelier de pelo
tonnage celui qui pose plus de problèmes
la cadence il est très dur la répétition
effrayante on étiquette 20 pilotes on
ramasse 20 pilotes ont fait un paquet de
vingt pilotes et on recommence en un
temps record aux 2500 à 3000 francs
selon le rendement ici on commence à 16
ans on arrête toujours avant 25 ans
ici tous les problèmes se cumulent
trajet fatigue dépression nerveuse
grossesse à orist cadence et bien sûr le
salaire qui reste de très loin la
revendication
un mur pour aller chercher les malades
iax qu'il n'y a rien à faire il faut
faire face à la concurrence
autrement dit il faut accepter le
travail pénible supprimer la femme
il faut essayer dans toute la mesure du
possible c'est ce que nous essayons
frère de limite et c'est ça mais il est
évident que les solutions radicales
s'imposent et que ce sera si on ne nous
aide pas plus dans ce domaine
la mécanisation vous aurez des emplois
plus intéressant mais moins nombreux
des emplois plus intéressant plus
enrichissant mais effectivement moins
d'emplois en attendant des conditions
meilleures ou des licenciements
les ouvrières inlassablement continuent
leur vie difficiles dans cet atelier de
lissage ces femmes portent un ballot de
8 kg toutes les minutes soit plus d'une
tonne par jour
certains postes il faut le dire comme
ici sans nettement moins pénible mais
ils demandent toujours une attention
soutenue une grande précision et un
inconscient
et puis il ya le bruit présent partout
mais surtout dans l'atelier de tissage
sandra plus tôt
certains se sont habitués à tout cela
ils nous disent les autres pains
nationalisation le conseil d'état saisi
depuis une semaine du texte de loi vient
de rendre son avis sur trois points la
nisation des actionnaires la
rétrocession des processions des
filiales de paris bike days
et puis la question des banques philippe
sassier faut bien dire qu'il s'agit que
de belleville est intéressant il s'agit
d' avis dont le gouvernement peut tenir
compte ou pas m'enfin comme un avis
important que celui du conseil d'état
lors qu'est ce qu'on peut dire bien le
conseil d'état reconnaît d'abord que les
arguments des pouvoirs publics pour
justifier les nationalisations
industriels sont conformes à la
constitution bon point pour le
gouvernement
il admet que certaines filiales des
groupes paribas et 16 retourne au
secteur privé le gouvernement craignait
que le conseil disent pourquoi rendre
ces quartiers et certains secteurs
d'activité et en nationalisées et
d'autres donc ce principe est admis là
aussi vont pas pour le gouvernement mais
en fait ces avis du conseil d'état
comporte un oui mais est annoncée
le oui mais mais le conseil année
correcte l'indemnisation proposée par le
gouvernement c'est à dire qu'on va
calculer la moyenne des cours d'une
action d'une société nationale is able
sur trois en 1978 79 et 80 cette prière
déterminera la valeur du nouveau titre
qui sera une obligation et qui sera
donnée aux anciens actionnaires mais dit
le conseil d'état il faudrait également
tenir compte des actifs et les acquis
c'est tout est propriété d'une
entreprise et puis de leurs bénéfices
mais là aussi ce n'est qu'un souhait ce
cas le plus grave c'est le nom si qu'il
concerne les banques en fait le conseil
d'état ne dit pas il ne faut pas
nationaliser les banques pays dit
pourquoi ne pas nationaliser aussi les
banques étrangères
en clair pour les juristes il faut une
égalité de traitement entre les banques
françaises aient les banques étrangères
alors pour le gouvernement fasse un
petit peu plus épineux il y à trois voix
d'abord peut suivre le conseil d'état
mais alors il se lance dans une série de
cascades de procès avec des actionnaires
étrangers
et ça c'est pas très amusant pour
gouvernement français deuxième solution
il n'écoute pas le conseil d'état mais
alors c'est le conseil constitutionnel
qui étudiera le projet après l'assemblée
qui risquent de s'opposer à ces
nationalisations de banques et dire
votre projet est anticonstitutionnelle
la sais pas
là c'était pas un avis troisième
solution le gouvernement on peut trouver
à une cote un peu mal taillée il peut
relever le seuil des dépôts qui est le
critère retenu pour nationaliser les
banques
un milliard que le remonter à 3 ou 4
milliards alors cela épargne les banques
étrangères mais cela est pas également
pas mal de banques françaises sur les 36
qui sont envisagées à ce moment là ce
sont les députés qui vont faire la
grimace alors qu'est ce que va faire le
gouvernement série a bien évidemment ce
que l'on peut dire comment tu sais qu'il
lui serait difficile de se lancer dans
trop de procès avec des gouvernements ou
des actionnaires étrangers ans en
mitterrand à l'unesco doute à l'heure il
rendait hommage au père teilhard de
chardin dont on fait en ce moment le
centième anniversaire de la naissance
hommage au philosophe passionnés dont
les prophéties généreuses ont été
reconnus par le chef de l'état d'un
peuple du vieux monde fatigué exemple
teilhard de chardin annonce que
l'histoire a toujours un sens qu'elle
est sans cesse crosse d'une promesse aux
peuples du tiers-monde affamés pillés il
promet l'avènement des masses humaines
leur accession à la plénitude de la vie
dans un monde réconcilié ou nation race
sexe ne seront plus que les facettes
d'une seule humanité
c'est dans l'unité enfin rendue possible
par le dépassement des contradictions
que se réalisera le but vous l'évoquez
tout à l'heure pierre-emmanuel de
l'épopée cosmique une civilisation de
l'amour on a pu oublier teilhard de
chardin personnalité hors du commun qui
toute sa vie aura lutté pour tenter de
concilier ou de réconcilier comme on
voudra la science et la foi
jean claude bach gounod leur présente
toutes les aventures spirituelles sont
un calvaire cette phrase de pierre
teilhard de chardin définit parfaitement
toute son existence jésuites et hommes
de science le père teilhard a voulu dès
sa jeunesse réconcilier la science et la
foi chrétienne
sa vie fut une succession d'aventurés
chercheur infatigable la première guerre
mondiale lui révèle l'énormité des
problèmes de la planète avec l'après
guerre il découvre la chine et la
sillonne avec passion l'épreuve l'attend
dans une lettre privée à un ami il tente
une explication personnelle du péché
originel un des dogmes du catholicisme
la lettre arrive au vatican en quelques
semaines pour le jésuite c'est la
disgrâce l'exil et le silence
obligatoire
teilhard de chardin devra se taire
jusqu'à son dernier souffle il se soumet
son épreuve aura une extraordinaire
fécondité sa réflexion ce fait
fondamental il entreprend des recherches
tous azimuts on le voit mettre à jour le
sinon trope l'un des premiers hommes de
la terre il participe à la croisière
jaune est écrit parallèlement des
ouvrages philosophiques qui circulent à
son insu sous forme de polycopiés par
tous et l'admiration pour l'originalité
et la profondeur de sa pensée
l'église elle maintient sa condamnation
le père teilhard de chardin est un
croyant
il obéit fatigué il reprend la route
c'est la belgique l'afrique du sud
l'amérique latine et enfin les états
unis où il meurt soumis mais brisée le
jour de pâques 1955 paléontologues
théologien philosophe teilhard de
chardin fut aussi un visionnaire
peut-être est-ce ce qu'on lui pardonne à
le moins l'histoire aujourd'hui lui rend
justice personne l'activité du pôle
république la conférence de presse le 24
septembre jeudi prochain longue
conférence de presse qui sera
retransmise dans l'après midi en direct
par antenne 2 et puis au début d'octobre
les 7 et 8 une rencontre à la che avec
le chancelier schmidt
aujourd'hui il recevait le président
tchadien goukouni oueddei apparemment
très satisfait de son premier contact
avec le nouveau pouvoir français que si
giscard était au pouvoir
je ne viendrai pas compte tenu de sa
position je ne viendrai pas et si je
suis venu donc il ya eu un changement
politique profond dans ce pays ce qui
veut dire que le régime actuel comprend
mieux que le gouverneur et sans
précédent des problèmes tchadien et
aussi de tout lâcher
penser ça n'a pas gâché par une
amélioration de l'aide militaire
financière vous est accordée si vous
preniez sur l'aide tout court je
pourrais vous répondre facilement mais
pour les deux militaires je ne pense pas
que nous mêmes nous demande rien il n'ya
des militaires ou français puisque le
régime actuel alj expériences du passé
des forces françaises au tchad et nous
aussi connaissant parfaitement de ce que
les français d'alors ont fait dans notre
pays nous ne sommes pas disposés à
demander une force militaire sur le plan
tous vous crever l'oeil qui répondait à
une question de philippe rochot ocha de
la ville de guéréda a été reprise par
l'armée gouvernementale
cuba fidel castro l'ambassade de france
à l'heure du déjeuner pour la première
fois depuis cinq ans et claude estier
vice présidente de la commission des
affaires étrangères à l'assemblée qui
était en visite à la havane
et puis à grand rapids au michigan
n'aura pu de rencontre entre ronald
reagan et valéry giscard d'estaing qui
ne se connaissait pas jusqu'à lors
l'ancien président français était
l'invité de gerald ford pour
l'inauguration de la bibliothèque qui
porte son nom
on n'a rien en a aussi profité pour
rencontrer le président mexicain et le
premier ministre canadien
cette gerald ford l'ancien président des
états unis qui invitait quelques-uns des
chefs d'état de gouvernement au pouvoir
durant les trente mois de sa présidence
c'est la première fois depuis le 10 mai
que l'ancien président de la république
française rencontrée à l'étranger des
personnalités politiques en exercice au
cours d'une manifestation officielle
avec ronald reagan
valéry giscard d'estaing parlait des
problèmes mondiaux notamment les
relations est-ouest
mais la situation politique française
n'a pas été évoquée pendant ses
entretiens entretien particulièrement
cordiaux et qui ont duré plus longtemps
que prévu
d'une certaine façon valéry giscard
d'estaing tu préfère encore voyager à
l'étranger avant une éventuelle rentrée
politique
alors maintenant c'est d'étonnantes
affaires de défaillance de distributeurs
automatiques de billets le juge
d'instruction d'agen a inculpé dextro
cris et a écroué
le cafetier de fumel qui avait réussi à
soustraire deux cent dix mille francs à
deux agences du crédit agricole à l'aide
d'une simple carte magnétique alors
comment cela est il possible et surtout
y at il eu fraude
l'enquète de thierry gandillot oui par
celui qui une nuit pendant quatre heures
et 12 minutes lui avait délivré pas
moins de 2000 95 billets de 100 francs
l'ordinateur car la machine avait
enregistré toutes ses opérations et les
gendarmes ont tué aucune difficulté à
retrouver la carte de crédit les billets
et le fraudeur
l'homme a été inculpée puis écrouée mais
il n'est pas sûr qu'il soit condamné et
les banquiers eux-mêmes restent très
prudents quelle est la part de
responsabilité c'est aux tribunaux de
répondre il est exact que la machine n'a
pas bien marché
il est exact aussi ce monsieur a retiré
beaucoup d'argent beaucoup puisqu'il en
avait sur s'enfonce de défaut ils
avaient l'intention puisqu'il avait même
déclaré sa carte avant comme perdue oui
non disons qu'il ya un certain nombre de
choses
ce monsieur a fait une erreur il a
profité d'une faiblesse de la machine et
d'aytré dit nos jugements embarras des
banquiers mais aussi inquiétudes des
juristes la fraude informatique n'est
pas une fraude
comme les autres quant aux machines
elles sont toujours aussi vulnérable
elles sont en pratique extrêmement
vulnérables simplement on n'a aucune
information des atteintes réalisé à
mesure où les banquiers ne veulent pas
donner des informations sur ce problème
et juridiquement juridiquement il y à un
vide complet et en l'occurrence tous
fraudeurs c'est qu'il n'y a presque
aucune sanction
pourquoi n'y a pas de sanction il ya un
vide juridique une incapacité à prendre
en compte les données de l'informatique
et d'automatismes on peut voler des
choses on peut voler des biens
on peut voler de l'argent on ne veulent
pas encore aujourd'hui de l'information
le quartz est désormais de madère à
partir du mois prochain tous les jeudis
si les dirigeants du pmu avait remarqué
que cela leur procurait quelques 5
millions de francs dans jeux
supplémentaires par rapport à un tiercé
ordinaire
et puisque nous parlons jeux d'argent le
point maintenant sur l' enquête à la
fraude au palm beach de cannes le
directeur général vient d'être déféré
devant le parquet de grasse il devrait
être inculpé dans la soirée daniel
leconte l'avait récemment rencontré à la
faveur d'une tout autre enquête la
majorité il est certain que pour les
recettes d'un établissement comme le
nôtre cela représentait une bonne
proportion de ses recettes peut-être 1%
c'était en août dernier il de félix nous
expliquer les comportements des joueurs
étrangers et la part qu'il prenait dans
les revenus du casino
aujourd'hui ce sont peut-être ces mêmes
joueurs qui sont à l'origine de la
sphère qui touche yves de félix et ses
deux adjoints du service des jeux du
panic la sphère des clients fortunés
aller en arabe qui font les beaux jours
du palm beach dans une période où les
gros joueurs français se font rares pour
conserver cette clientèle ont fait
quelques entorses aux règles qui
régissent le milieu les sommes perdues
par ses joueurs sont restitués aux plus
malchanceux d'entre elles d'autres elles
sont même gracieusement offert par la
maison
les cadeaux qui selon rives de félix
devait permettre de retenir ses joueurs
on évalue à 4 millions de francs les
sommes ainsi détourné 4 millions qui
échappe au contrôle fiscal
on sait en effet que l'état perçoit 60%
des bénéfices des casinos et que les
villes touche une redevance de 15 % sur
la côte d'azur après l'arrestation
d'yves de félix on s'attend peut-être à
d'autres inculpations pas si maintenant
des images spectaculaires et il convient
d'en avertir dès maintenant les jeunes
enfants et les âmes sensibles il s'agit
de la mort de ce torero amateurs qui
avaient voulu comme ça se fait
régulièrement dans les arènes faire
mieux qu'un professionnel en
l'occurrence le corps de baisse
seulement là la mort était au rendez
vous et la foule a hué le corps de
baisse qui envisagent même d'arrêter sa
carrière
la trique simpson jones c'est lui qui
avait dit à sa soeur avant sa première
grande corrida cette phrase célèbre ne
pleure pas angelita car ce soir où je
t'achèterai une maison ou bien tu
porteras mon deuil
il y a plus de vingt ans de cela depuis
il est devenu le plus adulé mais aussi
le plus contesté du torero mais il ya
une fin à tout et fernando sanchez tiên
chocolatées et peut-être l'homme qui
dans un instant de folie avant-hier a
mis fin à la carrière delporte dressent
car ce jeune est spontané haut
c'est-à-dire candidats torero a voulu
que l'on parle de lui pour cela il a
sauté dans l'arène alors que le picador
commencé à taquiner un jeune taureau de
485 kg dans un instant cet homme va
mourir en corner mortellement à deux
reprises el cordobès n'a pas bougé on le
lui reproche
mais at on oublié que c'est justement
grâce à de tels coups de folie que
certains grands noms de la tauromachie
mondiale ont débuté parmi lesquels el
cordobès lhimer alors n'est-il pas
possible qu'il ait voulu donner sa
chance à ce jeune homme comme jadis on
la lui donner fernando sanchez diane
chocolatées mort mais il n'est peut-être
pas le seul car bien que l'homme manuel
benitez soit encore vivant la légende
del cordobès c'est probablement arrêter
ici dans cette petite arène d'albas est
mort
en tennis championnat de france de
tennis donc qu'annick noah en finale il
a battu en demi-finale sur le score de
4-6 6-3 6-2 6-2 jérôme potier et l'ami
finale tulasne roger vasselin a été
interrompu par la nuit
et puis maintenant la météo avec laurent
broomhead oui malheureusement le temps
se gâte vous l'avez vu nous avons
retrouvé la plus on avait presque perdu
l'habitude ans et puis s'en vont vers
l'italie du coup ce pour samedi c'est
l'accalmie mais l on nous annonce pour
dimanche le retour des nuages et donc la
tempête
attention donc y revenir gardons un
petit coup d'oeil juste sur les
températures relevées à 14h et avec la
pluie elles sont en baisse des 15 16
degrés du côté du nord-ouest et
seulement dans le sud est ce du 25
degrés qui était encore correcte avec le
soleil la carte pour demain et les
nuages qui arrose une bonne partie du
pays s'éloigne vers le sud est demain on
les retrouve le matin depuis toutes les
régions maternelle jusqu'aux alpes et
puis même jusqu'aux vosges un peu plus
dans le nord ensuite ils se dirigeront
en prenant un caractère orageux vers
l'extrême sud-est et vers la corse avant
de disparaître partout ailleurs bien on
va retrouver le soleil est tout de même
de nombreux passages nuageux encore des
averses principalement dans le nord et
surtout le matin donc de belles
éclaircies alternant et les nuages
malheureusement le soir voyez ici ce
symbole depuis que je cachais le voilà
il arrive ce sont ces nuages qui
reviendront dans la soirée sur la
bretagne et dans la nuit qui donneront
des vents forts soufflant soufflant en
tempête sur les côtes de l'atlantique de
la manche et de la mer du nord ça veut
dire pour dimanche la traversée d'une
grande ligne depuis avec des vents forts
donc un dimanche humide qui se préparent
les températures pour demain toujours 10
12 degrés au lever du jour et 20 environ
l'après midi sauf bien sûr dans le
sud-ouest et le sud-est où décidément il
continue de faire un peu d'été voilà un
confrère rajeuni la nouvelle version du
matin magazine
désormais reparaît donc tous les samedis
ce soir dernier journal 22h55 présenté
par alain valentini quid maintenant 2010
vous entraînera au palais des sports
pour les derniers préparatifs de carmen
passer une bonne soirée et une bonne fin
de semaine maladie